The question is pros and cons of surgeries and biopsies when you have cancer in order to answer that question, I had to pull up this slide again.
So when we talk about surgery with cancer, it's all about trying to make sure we're not operating this guy right here.
We've had a lot of different conference calls and chats and Zoom calls and slide presentations out of EMTOR.
So to refresh your idea of what EMTOR is, is EMTOR is basically your growth pathway.
So EMTOR is up-regulated, that means it's stimulated when growth needs to take place.
And healing from an injury is growth.
So if you can understand that if I cut my hand, it has to scar over or I will bleed to death.
So it scars over actually quite quickly within a couple hours to a couple days depending on how deep that cut is.
Now how does it do that? It's not magic. It does that by up-regulated EMTOR because normally is my hand looking at the back of my hand between my thumb and my first figure, the web of my hand is what I'm looking at.
How often are those cells replaced? How often are those cells replaced in my hand and my skin? How about once every 12 weeks?
So that's not really growing too fast, is it? But how often are those cells replaced if I cut myself?
They're replaced about once every two minutes because it's building black, a scar, a wound, it's healing that.
And in a matter of a couple of weeks that wound, depending again how deep I cut myself, will be scarred over and pretty much healed up.
Well, how can it do that if it's only replacing cells once every 12 weeks? Well, it has to tremendously up-regulate this pathway, this EMTOR pathway.
So that cells are replicated, messenger RDA and glycolysis is up-regulated and in order to do that, in order to make new cells, in order to create a scar wound in order to heal that tissue.
So it is when we do surgery. So if I'm going to do surgery to do a biopsy or do surgery to remove a mass in my breast, then in order to heal, I have to up-regulate EMTOR.
If I don't, I will just bleed to death and die. So it's not that we don't want to up-regulate EMTOR if we're healing from a wound, you have to.
But do we want to create a wound? Sometimes it's necessary. So sometimes, yes, it's beneficial to debalk a cancer and to surgically remove the large mass there.
So our body can heal that and we can do all these other things to be able to heal that cancer that wound there.
But certainly doing surgeries that are maybe more elective surgeries might not be the best thing in what my cancer is active.
So if I'm in a stage of my cancer where I'm doing really well, and it's everything settled down, and let's say I do an IVG test in my IVG scores, a 12, and now is this a good time to have my herdeous surgery.
Yeah, that might be a good time to have a herdeous surgery right now, because I do want to deal with this herdea that I have, if that's caused problems with my digestion, I'm worried about having problems with it.
That was a good time to do the herdeous surgery. It is a good time to do this herdeous surgery, but I'm not doing well with my cancer. I'm feeling really fatigued. I'm not feeling well. I did an IVG score. It's a 27.
No, probably not a good time to do herdeous surgery right now. And there's probably not a lot of doctors that would do a herdeous surgery at you either.
But there are surgeries that people do do post cancer surgery, like doing a mastectomy. Well, that's a big surgery that's going to highly upregulate him tour, which is not necessarily good for that person's cancer.
But secondly, then they go and do reconstructive surgery. So that's one thing, if you better own me very long, that's not something I'm a big fan of, because that's an elective surgery. And I know it affects your psyche and all this kind of stuff.
So we could talk about that for days, but that's not maybe the best thing to do for the cancer cells that are still left.
So elective surgery is possibly not. So yes, there's a time to go back to that question. Is there a time that we do surgery? Yes.
Is it the time we do biopsies? Yes. Is it always the best thing to do? No, you just have to understand you are upregulated a pathway when you do that.